packy naughton we talked a lot about his
name and about his heritage and boston
and his road here
carlos correa after a four hit night
last night bumped up to the cleanup spot
here's the pitch that one hits off the
mall but over to renifo second for one
relay to first that's a double play
bottom of the first and you're looking
at jose or keaney the right-hander that
will be starting for your houston astros
on the season this will be his 18th
start he has looked very good 70 strike
percentage leads all of major league
baseball in the time that he has been
out there
ready to go at least 90 plus pitches
tonight hey look what i found jose or
kitty on a comebacker
loves it for the final out of the inning
two out double one man left on base
scoreless after one
lead off man on for kyle tucker d.h for
the second straight day
tucker sends one high in the air to
right field all the way back is rojas
looking up good home run
kyle tucker
drives one deep to right field
home run 27 and the astros lead this
game two to nothing
there's a couple guys in that asteroids
dugout that do not want to hear us
talking about realignment because it
would take him out of this ballpark this
guy right here kyle tucker loves hitting
against the
los angeles angels
and he likes hitting in this ballpark
too here's 11 miss
diaz diaz hits the ball hard to center
field back on it lagaris and he'll look
up back to back jacks
ds bows tucker hits one to the rocks and
the celebration is on second time the
astros have gone back to back in three
games now
it was siri and mccormick a couple of
days ago
now it's tucker and diaz
and the astros are exploding here in the
second inning second inning and the
angels down three nothing jack mayfield
mayfield
deep
mayfield
wow
that was high
and i mean
high and it's out of here captain jack
against his former team his tent double
figures in home runs for the captain oh
captain
jack mayfield
that ball was crushed a way to answer
that one right back after a couple home
runs by the astros here's where you're
releasing this pitch here's your arm
speed on this
2-2 bouncer up the middle fletch
backhands and
all throws we might as well get it out
of the way all right gold doubloon yes
that is an excellent play that is a long
throw an off balance throw
from fletch
and kids watching at home never try to
do that it's a pitcher use that bare
hand especially when you have fletch
behind you his biggest proponent for
gold glove and he's got lots of them is
joe madden
[Music]
mayfield center field myers goes back
squares up on the track
and makes the catch
that ball hit a long way but it stays in
the yard and it stays 3-1
the astros getting to 200 home runs this
year
with the blast by tucker in the second
now the astros never hit that many when
they played in the astrodome as altuve
belts one deep to left going back on it
gosselin at the wall and it's
gone two-run home run for altuve and the
astros lead it five to one on altuve's
29th of the year
that's too shy of his career high he set
two seasons ago
and the astros now with three home runs
in this ball game lead by four
[Applause]
nine game hit streak for altuve who now
has 78 runs batted in
astros lead 5-1 threatening for more
when the base is loaded and what out
kyle
tyler facing oled miss diaz where the
base is loaded
as diaz shoots one into left field
that'll score one run
also being waved around is jordan
alvarez and he'll score
astros add two to their lead it's now
seven to one
[Music]
led miss diaz
a three rbi game with a home run and now
two rbi single
it's always fun having such a diverse
group go out there but how about the
fact that the
cuban infielder drove in the cuban first
baseman and the cuban left fielder we
haven't really talked about it too much
yet because we've talked about a lot of
different subjects
as louise read hippo bats
ground ball towards second altuve to
correa and they will turn the double
play sharply hit by red heapo but he hit
it right at jose
and that'll do it for the angels in the
fifth 7-1 houston now donato walked to
begin the astros four run fifth he's
also grounded out tonight
1 0 pitch maldonado sends one high and
deep to right field all the way back to
the wall leaping and it's over the wall
and gone
martine maldonado on back-to-back
knights hitting a home run
this one out to right center
lagarres just missed it and maldi has a
dozen home runs on the year it's eight
to one
[Applause]
[Music]
martine maldonado
so altuve at third guriel at second
alvarez at first nobody out
as he sends this one towards right field
rojas towards the line makes the play
tagging is altuve he'll score easily
also moving up a base is julie guriel
who tagged and moved to third
fly ball here could score another run
instead it's a chopper to the right side
they'll make the plane a second for one
and tucker beats the return throw runs
gonna score that fielder's choice will
give the astros an even 10.
gosling hits one to left center field
hits it deep alvarez back at the wall
a double and a homer for the goose
the angels
get three quick ones
the goose loose with that swing three
run a home run shohei you'd love to see
more opportunities with guys on base
especially guys in scoring position
oh tony
deep and high
and gone and 45
boy what a swing that was i love the
reaction even in a 10-4 game a swing
like that and the sound off the back
for shohei ohtani number 45 time mike
trout
second all-time on the halo list for
home runs
so a rocket single and a mammoth home
run
shohei ohtani
swaying in a miss ball game over
astros reduce the magic number down to
four
as they win tonight ten to five